our late car is still a thing if the
millions of data points available were
tracked in real time whether Street
closures and merchants ease historical
trends cars might never be late again
all that usable data could create a more
efficient and reliable subway system to
processing split second writer data and
track conditions to predict and avoid
any breakdowns
and what about commerce smarter banking
could easily spot a single fraudulent
transaction among billions of real ones
in a matter of seconds cell phones if
they have more processing power and
higher throughputs I'd have 10 million
more noobs in the palm of my hands even
food every plant fruit or vegetable
could have its own IP address by growing
them in ultra efficient smart farms
processing countless data sources such
as soil nutrients air quality humidity
irrigation and more insights could be
collected to help grow the perfect
whatever you want every single time
wherever you want
you